dogs got a new girlfriend not yet I
don't dogs got a new girlfriend
dogs got a new girlfriend I said hey mom
I'll make you famous and they're not
really my girlfriend you know so I'm not
saying I'm not gonna have it because I
will I'm not gonna get married as I told
you ever Dog the Bounty Hunter seems to
have had a change of heart since that
conversation back in September et can't
confirm the reality star whose real name
is Dwayne Chapman is now engaged to his
girlfriend Francie freeing a rep for the
reality star tells et they're very happy
and looking forward to a long life
together this news comes just 10 months
after his wife Beth Chapman's death any
time they see you with a woman they say
old dogs already moved on he's gone
wreck right
did you ever talk about that oh yeah
well yes because both of us did and I
said to her I know you're gonna date
look at you baby you know I ain't stupid
but please don't ever get married again
and she said you better not take the
name off my name off your chest I said
I'm to brass baths I'll put her name
when that said you better not add so
don't take that off and don't get
married in an interview with the Sun dog
opened up about his future plans with
his new fiancee saying that he quote
would love to have the biggest wedding
there's ever been
francy also revealed Chapman popped the
question at his home in Colorado where
they've been quarantined together Beth
dogs fifth wife died in June 2019 after
a battle with throat cancer the two were
married for 13 years
when et spoke with the reality star back
in February the death of his wife was
still weighing heavy on his heart oh
yeah I miss her though it gets it's
eight months it doesn't that's the worst
part it just seems like yesterday and
they say time heals all wounds no it
don't know no what do you miss most
about that her calm at her touch or
smell her encouragement
her I'm gonna hire a real bounty hunter
few who gets his guy her teasing me her
did we say the blessing before we eat
she was kind of everything yeah I kind
of hate to admit that cuz I'm such a
macho macho man but she was the glue
that held my family together and during
that combo just three months ago doc
told us that there wasn't a special lady
in his life yet no no special lady right
now but I I think you know it's almost
time where I could start I'm not I could
maybe go out with the girl and eat and
you know and date a little if that's a
date we do how do you date today when it
comes to how dogs kids feel about their
dad moving on after Beth's death here's
what he told et well the girls are very
upset because the other girls I might be
looking at or I may say so dad they just
like you because you're Dog the Bounty
Hunter they don't like you because
you're Dwayne or dad so their boys are
like dad do you know if you love them if
you like them we're for you whatever you
decide what the girls are like
[Music]